Ihnen auch bereits Pflanze gießen werdet
mir Serie
[Musik]
[Applaus]
Menschen sind aufgebrochen um sich einen
Traum zu erfüllen es ist ihr erster Tag
auf der berühmten oder
Skitour quer durch die Alpen von
Chamonix nach Zermatt
80 km
7000 Höhenmeter in 6 Tagen von Hütte zu
Hütte
die Gruppe hat sich heute zum ersten Mal
gesehen
Olympiasiegerin dominique Gisin
Platten
David Fasel ist ihr Bergführer zusammen
mit Bruno Jelk dem ehemaligen
rettungschef von Samad
auch dabei der CEO der Allianz Gruppe
Schweiz
ein Heilpädagoge
eine Tochter mit ihrem Vater und
eine junge Frau den gedenken an ihre
verstorbene Mutter auf der Tour mit
dabei ist
die rote Route ist die Skitour durch die
höchsten Berge der Alpen ein Mythos auf
der ganzen Welt
an ihrem ersten gemeinsamen Abend in der
Hütte lernt sich die Gruppe gegenseitig
kennen alle sind gespannt mit wem sie
unterwegs sind
[Applaus]
[Musik]
ich habe
noch dies klar schaffe in rennschuhen
den Zeit hast ich finde ich höre dich
rufen schaffe und ich probiere mich
selbständig machen und melde mich auch
entscheide viel mutiger werde mich bis
jetzt nicht
erlaubt und jetzt entscheidet und der
entscheidet nicht er hat mit dem Ärzte
Oberstufe Lehrer
was erwartet die Gruppe die rote Ruth
ist eine Herausforderung für alle die
sie wagen
Bergführer David Fasel aus verbi führt
seit Jahren regelmäßig Gäste durch diese
Route
der Start zur Tour war heute morgen den
Arsch und ihr Lieben Chamonix von dort
ging es hoch zur Arsch und ihre Hütte
morgen wird die Gruppe weiter gehen zur
gabandi Trier in der Schweiz
dann über Welpi hoch zur Cabanossi
von dort Cindy kavandi dies ins be back
to book da
die Ankunft ist am 6. Tag in Zermatt
7 1000 Höhenmeter 80 km meistens auf
3000 m Höhe inmitten der 4000 warten auf
das Team
[Musik]
der nächste Morgen beginnt mit einer
unangenehmen Überraschung
Notfallmanagement
was
wird heute mehr Verantwortung übernehmen
müssen
[Applaus]
Seebachtal langsam doch nicht dazwischen
zwischen an
[Applaus]
[Musik]
Feuerwehr
Bauhof Stockstadt
die nächste Schwierigkeit wartet bereits
der Aufstieg zum Goldi Chardonnay
[Musik]
jetzt muss ich das erst so
ich warte jetzt mal weg die schiesse a&g
Open rufe Voicemail
oppressor alarm Passage
aufgebrochen ist die Gruppe heute in der
Arsch auf die erhöhte jetzt sind sie im
ersten Aufstieg auf den Col di
Chardonnay
weiter geht's über das für Meterriss
alleine zur Besteigung der equity to
seal ist die Garantie Trier auf 3170
Meter
über zehn Kilometer und 1000 und 40
Höhenmeter beinhaltet dieser Tag
darf ich in 5 bis 7 Stunden reine
Laufzeit geplant
es ist der erste Test Bergführer David
muss herausfinden wie sicher die Gruppe
unterwegs ist
[Musik]
direkt hinter dem 72-Jährigen Paul seine
Tochter Yolanda
jeder sucht seinen eigenen Rhythmus
knapp 3000 m Höhe nicht nur Carmen und
Peter auch die ehemalige Spitzensportler
hin dominique Gisin
Bergführer Bruno Jelk folgt langsam
geschwächt von seiner Magenverstimmung
Cannabis Trenker
Sonnenbrille
Besteigung
[Gelächter]
700m Aufstieg auch die ehemaligen
Weltcup Fahrerin sind technisch
gefordert
wir machen opfere
wie geht es mit Bruno weiter die Gruppe
ist groß es braucht zwei Bergführer um
sicher durch die Woche zu kommen
nach drei Stunden ist der Col di
Chardonnay in Griffey das Tor zu den
Walliser Alpen
[Musik]
3323 m sind erreicht die Grenze zwischen
Frankreich und der Schweiz
dahinter ein steiles Kulmbach
[Musik]
David sicher die Passage mit einem Seil
dass ich nicht nur Visite für mich
richtig
gurtpeitsche
[Musik]
[Applaus]
2000 Staiger
Einsturz am Anfang der Tour wäre
verhängnisvoll
aber dominik ist dich solche Passagen
gewohnt vom Freeriden in ihrer Heimat
Engelberg
[Musik]
Jolanta nutzt derweil die Pause für eine
SMS an ihre zwei Kinder
[Musik]
die Grippe ist jetzt seit fünf Stunden
unterwegs die Sonne brennt auf den
Gletscher es geht hinauf zum nächsten
Feld Übergang zum finetra du es allein
vorbei und offenen
[Musik]
probiere mal systematisch den Beruf
Bender
zur Sicherheit
steiler Aufstieg bis zum 3. alleine und
es ist erst der zweite Tag der Tour
[Musik]
Vater und Tochter sind die ersten
umorismo
[Musik]
nicht alle haben sich für den
zusätzlichen Gipfel entschieden
Lunow fährt mit paul und Peter über den
Gletscher direkt zur Körper Nutria
während die anderen wieder aufsteigen
zur Aiguille du tue
[Musik]
es ist unterdessen Meter nach dem
eiskalten morgen herrschen jetzt
Sommertemperaturen auf 3000 Metern Höhe
die Trinkflaschen sind fast leer der
Proviant gegessen
auch Olympiasiegerin dominique Gisin
kämpft Unterhitze
und die Kletterpartie steht noch bevor
[Musik]
Peter Bruno und Paul sind fast schon am
Ziel liegt aber drin ist dann alter
Steinbau die erste Hütte auf Schweizer
Boden
übernachtet wird auf 3170 mich
Bruno
Stange
[Applaus]
hat dein Caddy wochenlang
drum Hit
[Musik]
alle sind mitgekommen auch Carmen
nach über sieben Stunden ist schließlich
der erste Gipfel der Tour erreicht
[Musik]
schweren Herzens
nach über 8 Stunden werden die
Gipfelstürmer in der banditry unerwartet
[Musik]
[Gelächter]
Ralf wieder der Bergführer der für das
Filmteam zuständig ist hat sich Carmen
angenommen
[Musik]
[Gelächter]
Severin Moser ist ehemaliger Zehnkämpfer
und trainiert noch heute täglich als CEO
bei der Allianz Schweiz wird der 3500
Mitarbeiter und hat sich vorgenommen in
dieser Woche keine Mails beantworten
erzähl mir die Probleme der Bruno hat
mich nicht so
verlogen
[Gelächter]
[Musik]
am nächsten Morgen ist um 4 Uhr dreißig
Uhr tagwacht
jeden Tag übernachtet die Gruppe
gemeinsam in einer anderen Hütte
der Ablauf des Magens folgt einem Ritual
zuerst den Rucksack packen das Gepäck
für eine Woche tragen alles selber 10
Kilo inklusive Steigeisen und Pickel
wiegt ein Rucksack
bevor es losgeht findet die Kontrolle
der lawinensuchgeräte statt
das Wetter ist bisher stabil und auch
die Prognosen sehen gut aus
[Musik]
die kalten Morgenstunden sind richtig
gegen Sicherheit die Gruppe muss gegen
14 Uhr in der nächsten Hütte sein dass
am Nachmittag wieder heiß werden soll
und damit die Gefahr von
Nassschneelawinen steigt
[Musik]
jeden Tag immer weiter nie ein Tag in
Ruhe in über 3000 Metern Höhe
das ist eine der Herausforderungen der
hoothoot
große
Kamera
kannst du mit Backspace
wieder ist es Dominic Gisin die als
einzige die Abfahrt Markt
[Applaus]
[Musik]
die dritte Etappe führt von der Garantie
Trio auf den goldener grand Louis eine
lange Abfahrt bis hinunter ins Tal nach
laffoley
dann mit dem Bus nach Verviers und mit
der Bahn wieder hoch zur Cabane Mofa
600 Meter Aufstieg und 1700m Abfahrt
sind heute zu überwinden
es ist das Erlebnis der Skitour aber
auch die Ruhe die Einsamkeit die alle
auf der Hut Hut gesucht haben
für eine kurze Zeit aus dem
Verpflichtung des Alltags ausbrechen
sich Zeit dafür nehmen wovon man
geträumt hat und dem Leben ein neues
Kapitel hinzufügen
wieder sind es lange Aufstieg mit
fellski über weite gleicher steile cool
was die nur mit Steigeisen zu bewältigen
sind
Karl Wagner
visionale
Geohot
Stocksattel
und die Severin und Franzi machen so
schafft
waldziegelhütte am Seil
Luna
vor ihnen liegt nun das 200m Stelle cool
war über den Col de la County die
heutige Schlüsselstelle
[Musik]
heute ist David als Bergführer besonders
gefragt
[Musik]
das
Grüße gefällt das Problem
ruhig und gelassen hat Yolanda
ihrerseits schafft durch die steile
Flanke gefühlt
[Musik]
Bergführer David Fasel fährt mit Dominik
Fränzi und Severin vorneweg
[Musik]
Bergführer Ralf Weber folgt mit Yolanda
und der zweiten Gruppe
[Musik]
die schneebedeckte Fläche des Gletschers
ist türkisch immer wieder tauchen
unvermittelt riesige Spalten auf die wir
die Gruppe schwer einsehbar sind
[Musik]
oder aber es
macht noch Spaß
Paul hast du so vorgestellt oder
wie schnell noch mal Kuss von mir ja
das ist sowieso
tschüss was
in
dieser Zeit noch nie länger von ihm
getrennt
weiter geht die heutige Etappe per Bus
nach Verviers dann mit der Bahn ins
Skigebiet von Mofa Sommer vor Hütte auf
2457 m
die Hütte steht mitten im Skigebiet und
ist mit allem Komfort ausgestattet
wir sind gleich
nach 3 Tagen eine erste Dusche
[Musik]
Zeit zu entspannen
oder wie im Fall von Dominique Gisin und
Fränzi Aufdenblatten auf ihre Beziehung
als Weltcup Pfarrerinnen und
Konkurrentinnen zurückzublicken
Aberglaube generell ist so speziell dass
er mit ihnen wohl meist fahre ich halt
noch so wenig Kontakt will in Wetzlar wo
hätte halt Courier Amroth aufgespielt
und jetzt ich mal verstreut
[Musik]
zerstört und das hilft ja deshalb
mit dem Umzug auch wenn sie zum Anrufer
sperren oder das ist wohl nicht klar bei
euch erklärt dass vor allem auch
[Musik]
die Gruppe wächst durch die
Herausforderungen und gemeinsame
Erlebnisse auf der Hut immer mehr zu
einem Team zusammen
[Musik]
neben Bruder noch telefoniert
[Applaus]
es folgt die rosablanche auf über 3000
Meter und danach eine lange Lauf Passage
am lucky dies bis zur Cavalettis
[Musik]
mit neun Stunden 17 km und 1800 m
Aufstieg ist es die längste Etappe der
Hutu
[Musik]
die erste Etappe für den langen Tag
startet auf der vereisten Piste des
Skigebietes
[Musik]
die Wettervorhersage ist immer noch gut
erste Blessuren machen sich bemerkbar
[Musik]
jeder kämpft für sich und versucht
seinen eigenen Rhythmus zu finden
denn heute ist nicht nur der längste
sondern auch einer der härtesten Tage
nicht nur körperlich sondern auch mental
[Musik]
serbisches Kinderlied
David
[Musik]
gegen Mittag wird es wieder heiß hinter
der
direkt in der Lawine liegt
[Musik]
ja feller.ch
schicke Spaghetteria
[Musik]
Reserven die am Morgen beim frühen Start
nicht alle zur Verfügung hatten
[Musik]
laufen nur laufen
alleine mit sich der Natur seine
Gedanken
stundenlang im gleichen hört keine
Ablenkung nicht
[Musik]
so beweglicher so wie er dass du mich
GDL Woche
öffne mir Luft der Woche
SOFT Plus
Sachbearbeiter
dass sie vorhin wieder auf
Paracord hat Fehler 3. 4. Tag ist immer
besser mit der Höhe
immer näher kommen Sie daraus Ablauf und
ihrem ziehen Samad
[Gelächter]
[Musik]
Dammbruch jetzt aus wann ich auch
aber das schafft die
Motivatoren
bevor sie das Matterhorn
der Weg führt weiter über die Besteigung
der rosa Blush
weiter unten im Tal im Nebel liegt der
lactease
David
deine Links suche Telefonnummer fahren
[Musik]
gemeinsame Reichenhaller die rosa Plüsch
[Applaus]
ein kurzes genießen und weiter geht es
hinunter in die Fläche entlang des
Lakritz
[Musik]
die Gruppe ist inzwischen seit 6 Stunden
unterwegs
der Nebel hat sich aufgelöst die
mittagshexe drückt Severin zieht mit
Dominic Gisin vorneweg gefolgt von Peter
heißt und Handlung mit saugen
technischen
aber dann gerne hier schlafen lach lach
und die mit dem Nordhang
aber
Werkzeugverleih
die Natur das Wetter sie können über
Leben und Tod entscheiden wie sich auch
auf der Autoroute einige Tage später
zeigen wird
die Gruppe hat sich inzwischen getrennt
David Welt mit Severin Fränzi Dominik
Jolanda und Peter die Strecke hoch über
dem Stausee hinweg über
Nassschneelawinen
Katja andere Mädels
richtige Dreieck
[Musik]
auch die schnellere Gruppe leidet unter
der frühlingswitze
[Musik]
ich schlafe der beliebte wir Baby wenn
minuten
naja ich super nein spüre nö nein
Ralf steck mit seiner Gruppe immer noch
unten am stauseefest
plötzlich ist die Schneedecke
Eisschollen und
Paul bleibt stecken
Fotos direkt zu dir
kurz vor dem Ziel und doch noch weit
[Musik]
H2O
Severin kämpft
[Applaus]
[Musik]
erschöpft und
H&M
[Musik]
[Applaus]
mein RVB
das sagst Orchidee Mountain oder so
unterwegs die
[Applaus]
gemeinsam noch einmal auf der Hut ein
Traum für beide
[Musik]
was denkt ihr das noch trees gehörigen
danach auf eine PDF Seite
[Gelächter]
nach über 10 Stunden erreicht doch
Carmen das Ziel
[Applaus]
[Musik]
die Hütte ist voll rund 120 Tourenfahrer
aus der ganzen Welt sind an diesem Tag
Ende April auf der AU tut unterwegs von
Hütte zu Hütte
[Musik]
Tag 5 vielleicht zum 5 Uhr morgens geht
es wieder weiter der Winter zugelegt
[Musik]
die Etappe beginnt in der Garantie diese
es folgt der Aufstieg über die goldene
lassen und ihn auf die pigne d'arolla
auf fast 4000 Meter
dann in unter über den Col de l'eveque
ins Biwak Dibbuk da
wieder muss die Gruppe eine 8 stündige
Tour mit über 14 Kilometern und 1500
Höhenmetern bewältigen
dönerschneider
die gestrige Tour hat Spuren
hinterlassen Carmen startet mit
Schmerzen
das Wetter ist noch gut doch die
Schlechtwetterfront rückt näher
eigentlich war sie bereits für den
heutigen Tag angekündigt
es ist Hochsaison auf der Hut Hut wie
heute sind im Frühling täglich
Skitourengänger aus der ganzen Welt in
Gruppen unterwegs um sich ihren Traum zu
erfüllen
Steinberger Hof auf dem vereisten
Gletscher dieses Mal mit Harscheisen den
Steighilfe na Tenshi geht es auf dem Col
de la Serpentine zu
[Applaus]
dann Stopp
Teilfeld 1 wann das Fels und Eis
Richtung Norden ab
darüber der vereiste Steilhang Sabine da
Roller es ist eine kritische
Schlüsselstelle
das ist schön
Ralf und David haben die Gruppe geteilt
am Seil und auf Steigeisen geht es nun
über den vereisten Steilhang
der Wind hat zugelegt es ist kalt
Vorboten der Schlechtwetterfront
[Musik]
Wiener Leben und Tod auf einer solchen
Tour beieinander liegen zeigt sich zwei
Tage später als eine andere Gruppe und
dieser Stelle in einen Sturm gerät die
Orientierung verliert und 7 Personen in
der Kälte ums Leben kommen
[Musik]
so schnell können sich die Verhältnisse
ändern so groß ist auch die
Verantwortung der Bergführer gegenüber
ihren Gästen dienen vertrauen
es brennt aber verbieten mir mehr zum
verunsichert und Bienenkorb ist LTE oder
4G
ja aber
wir haben
die letzten Schritte auf die Bühne der
Roller mit 3790 m dem Dach Tattoo
bei guten Bedingungen haben es alle
geschafft
Paul stand schon vor 50 Jahren zum
ersten mal genau auf diesen.
ja ich hier sind natürlich wieder
draußen
[Musik]
die wollten immer näher
und endlich wieder einmal eine Abfahrt
bevor es in die nächste Steigung geht
[Musik]
Nebel kommt auf es stimmt doch David
kennt den Weg
ihr Ziel heute ist das Biwak Dibbuk da
ein Biwak das hoch über dem Gletscher
liegt es ist nicht bewirtschaftet
verfügt aber über eine Kochgelegenheit
mit Brennholz
für eine letzte Nacht weg vom Rummel der
großen Hütten und nur noch einen Tag
entfernt vom Ziel dem Matterhorn und
Zermatt
[Musik]
biceps überhaupt morgen in Brake mit
deinem Handy
[Musik]
aber nicht welli.net
fablable
kurz vor dem Ziel noch einmal ein Moment
für alle darüber nachzudenken warum man
sich den Traum erfüllen wollte
ist JayJay ob ich auch noch Hilfe
und das Moment einfach gesehen ich
glaube das ist goldwert
wunderschön sie ja wirklich eine Woche
lang
wenig studiere und das ist schon
erholen Sie einfach mal so eben keine
unlösbare Probleme im Kopf Oma war nicht
sehr
[Gelächter]
Trixie solitär in Riegsee wie stark ist
das Benzin
mir Kaffee mit viel also
gerade gerne zeige es ist so schnell
vorbei gegangen habe also ja
ganz verschiedene
jedryka nee also ist das gar nicht
irgendwie Männer genau
wie sie sich wesentlich besser gelaufen
als dass sie denkt hat
ja Iris gar nicht so genau Phase
noch einmal um 5 Uhr aufstehen noch
einmal im Schein der Stirnlampen auf dem
gefrorenen Gletscher zum letzten
Aufstieg Verein
[Musik]
die Wut Wut ist auch eine Geschichte
über Menschen die sich vorher nicht
gekannt haben und an ihre Grenzen kam
[Musik]
die lernten mit Steigeisen zu klettern
sich zu überwinden und gemeinsames
Gruppe an das Ziel zu glauben
[Musik]
hallo
darf ich
[Musik]
[Applaus]
und zu Ende dieses Abenteuer nach sechs
Tagen in den hohen Bergen mit einem
Blick auf das Mathe auch
bevor sie hinunter fahren zurück in den
Alltag
denn manchmal ist es an der Zeit das zu
tun wovon man geträumt hat und dem Leben
ein neues Kapitel hinzuzufügen
[Applaus]
[Musik]
mein Schatz
nicht dass sie meinte
[Musik]
wurden präsentiert von fleurop.ch